[Music]
you
I'm so in love I'm losing my mind I
can't eat I can't sleep I can't work I
think Ivan procrastinate she's perfect
she's got this like she's inherently
nice and I'm dependable
but banana bar and where she's got like
an edge to her as well sometimes you see
it and she's just kind of reading a
magazine or she's she's looking out past
all the scratchcards
and she's just got this intensity like
she's felt pain before but she's
resilient to it mm-hmm she's got like
the characteristics of like a doctor or
a surgeon but this poetic mind as well
so she's like a poetry writing surgeon
yeah well if you say like that it makes
it sound stupid no it's great I'm really
happy for you so when's your next day oh
well so as I haven't met her she says
she works in the news agents so she's
behind the camera
someone said hello yeah and buy anything
yet I'm gonna talk to her soon
you
I went in again today
it's pretended I needed some cheddar and
nuts she seems so gentle and thoughtful
you know like like she's holding the
infinite wisdom of all ages in her head
forgot thongs are so uncomfortable
there's something elevated an
intrinsically noble of power you know
like she's human but she's higher than
us like she's made from some finer
material than the rest of us God our
bathroom is so disgusting
I'm gonna completely lose my rag if he
hasn't cleaned it
I bet she's so kind to everyone who
knows her and patient as well absolutely
disgusting there is no way in hell that
I'm doing that you do it for once
how can I put this she seems incapable
of having a banal thought well three for
two or knickers do I need any knickers
[Music]
I told you not to throw away my receipt
oh my god sticks
[Music]
it's been six hours how you're not ready
yet click this ticks hi it looks good
you look lovely Bertha it's time to go
okay yes
two minutes seconds okay
[Music]
it's not just me like everyone hates and
everyone has a problem with him but like
he's not the loan manager so they'd have
to do anything about it but I'm the way
[Music]
her hobbies been my hobbies my hobbies
are her hobbies just go out have day
trips just like that laughter Gower
London do stuff you know I mean yeah and
that the arguments and bickering and
fights and insecurity and farting
mountains aiya tea and meeting the
parents and falling oh no no no she's
not like that
you
you
what yesterday
yes yeah yeah no aren't gonna have a bag
that's big enough for that I'm sorry
oh yeah that's fine I'll just walk it
over my shoulder and yes I'm and no I'm
okay actually
[Music]
if you liked this film download our app
where you can view all our videos read
articles from the Book of Life and chats
with other students of the School of
Life